everyone likes to think of themselves as
a rational human being
it is tantamount to an insult and many
times embarrassing for you to perceive
or sense that your interlocutor
thinks of you as an
irrational philosopher
but is rationality an issue of opinion
does irrational mean that you simply
don't agree with me
[Music]
in science we have to define key words
and rational is one of them
because science is about rational
explanations
science only allows for rational
theories
if we cannot even visualize or imagine
the phenomenon or mechanism that the
speaker is explaining
what have we learned what have we
understood
now the fault sometimes lies with the
audience
maybe they lack the educational
prerequisites
the necessary foundations to understand
what one is saying
but what about phds are they off the
hook simply because they obtained a
10-year degree
here we're going to propose that for the
purposes of physics irrationality
involves the following criteria
redefining and moving concepts
for instance introducing casual figures
of speech and worn out cliches such as
transferring information
colliding wave functions
exciting a field
dilating time
and other such euphemisms in the main
body of the dissertation
failure to define a key word that makes
or breaks your theory or to use it
inconsistently throughout your
dissertation
for example defining energy as capacity
and using it as a three-dimensional
physical substance in the course of the
lecture
the explanation does not follow from the
assumptions
the prosecutors introduce a knife as
exhibit a
but their case is that the victim died
of poisoning
describing and claiming to have
explained
a common error is to think that
equations explain
they don't
mathematics is in its entirety a
language of descriptions it has no power
or authority to explain
since science is about explaining
mathematics plays no role in the branch
known as physics
proposed mechanisms don't work or cannot
even be imagined
can matter spontaneously create itself
from absolutely nothing surreptitiously
acquiring length width and height from
total vacuum
a film identifying each of the objects
on the big screen would certainly go a
long way to establish whether the
theorists visualize the theory
these criteria can be used consistently
and objectively to determine whether a
theory qualifies as rational
[Music]
you